Prof: Today,
we're going to embark on a
discussion about air quality
law.
And I'm going to start with
really an assertion by the
Environmental Protection Agency
that I've come to think of as a
myth of sorts,
when they have claimed that the
nation's air quality has
improved dramatically in the
past twenty-five years.
Well, how would you know if
that's true?
How would you contest that?
What kind of evidence would you
want?
And what we'll find today is
that your answer to this really
depends upon what pollutants you
choose to measure,
what you know about the
toxicity of different
pollutants,
where you measure the
pollutants, do you measure them
in a fixed monitor out in the
field someplace in the middle of
northeastern Connecticut?
Or do you do it next to a
highway in New Haven or
Bridgeport?
And how you spend your time.
Where do you spend the majority
of your time?
I bet it's not where EPA
measures pollutants.
The majority of your time is
spent indoors,
I would guess,
overwhelmingly indoors.
And how do you behave indoors?
And by that I mean,
how would your behavior affect
your exposure to pollutants
indoors?
These are all questions that
became apparent late in the
twentieth century,
are really important to know
whether or not law works.
And this law,
the Clean Air Act,
the pesticide law,
it has a very technical
character to it,
and I think that you can
understand by now in the course
that environmental law is not
just about making rules.
It's about understanding the
environment and how it works and
how it responds to different
kinds of human stresses.
And also, it's about what we
can do to relieve those
stresses.
So there's a technical side to
this that there is not in many
other forms of law.
So is the air quality
improving, and if not,
why?
So think about the different
kinds of legal strategies and
standards that have been
designed to control air quality
in history?
Well one is land use and zoning.
So thinking about how you'd
segregate different land uses.
So you keep the industrial
facilities or say the military
sites away from the residential
areas.
So this idea of segregation or
buffering land uses where you
know you have high levels of
emissions from those where
people reside away from schools.
This was one of the earliest
forms of attempted control.
And there are examples in
London back in the seventeenth
century of prohibiting certain
kinds of facilities,
rendering plants or plants that
produce a lot of smoke in the
air from being in residential
areas.
Another approach to controlling
air quality is the idea if
setting a ceiling or an
allowable emission limit.
So the idea that you would
chemical by chemical set an
allowable level of contamination
in the air has become really
central to the way that we've
thought about trying to manage
our health.
So have these policies been
developed in a way that's
precautionary,
to prevent significant
deterioration?
And as you look at the
structure of the Clean Air Act,
you'll see that the idea,
prevention of significant
deterioration,
is a really critical concept.
So we don't -- as a nation
we've decided we don't really
want to make the air quality
worse that it is.
That we're on a path toward
restoration or improvement in
quality.
We've also found that it's
important to think differently
about mobile sources than it is
about stationary sources.
And quite frankly,
if you were the administrator
of the Environmental Protection
Agency back in 1970 and you
walked into this problem of
having a zillion stacks in the
county that were emitting
dangerous chemicals,
you would concentrate on very
visible sources.
So it's a very different kind
of a problem,
and one where we've made more
progress because we could
identify the stack and we could
put monitors on those stacks,
than we face in indoor
environments,
when we don't really have any
understanding of the kinds of
chemicals that we're exposed to.
Trans-boundary flows of
pollution have been
traditionally very difficult to
control.
The Canadians are pretty upset
with us in the way that we
transfer much of the air
pollution that is produced in
the Midwestern United States up
across central and northeastern
Canada.
As is New York upset with Ohio
and the power plants in Ohio
that are burning more coal and
the pollutants from Ohio are
moving into New York.
So how do we control
trans-boundary movements across
state boundaries or across even
local boundaries,
or the most difficult situation
would be national boundaries.
Property rights to pollute.
This is an interesting idea.
And really, this idea that you
could set an allowable ceiling
and instead of telling every
person that lives in that region
that they have to comply with a
certain level of emission,
that you put a cap on the total
emission for that region,
and then gradually you lower
that cap down.
So this is the idea of cap and
trade.
And it really grew out of an
attempt to control acid
precipitation associated with
sulfur dioxides and nitrogen
oxides that caused a whole array
of problems,
including loss of certain
species.
So in the Adirondacks,
I take a seminar to the
Adirondacks in the fall every
year.
All the lakes above 2,500 feet
in elevation don't have trout in
the Adirondacks because of the
way that SO_2 and NOx
create acid aerosols that rain
down and make those lakes too
acidic for those fish to grow.
Buildings around the world have
been deteriorated,
especially if they're made out
of limestone because of acid
aerosols.
The red spruce at high
elevations in the Northeastern
U.S., up on Mt.
Washington or up in the
Adirondacks or the Green
Mountains, those red spruce are
in decline.
And the decline is caused by
the fact that clouds hang over
the tops of these mountain peaks
and the fog itself is acid,
so that it's causing
vulnerability to different
illness.
So capping and trading is now
believed to be the more
efficient way to reduce
pollution.
The idea began initially with
Environmental Defense,
when it was called
Environmental Defense Fund,
but it now has become really
the cornerstone of attempts to
control the CO_2
problem that we face.
Technology forcing standards:
so what if your technology is
not capable of reducing emission
to the level that you want it to
be?
Well, you can set an
aspirational standard.
By that I mean that you give an
industry or a sector a certain
period of time within which they
would have to reduce their
emissions.
By the way, it's only fitting
that I can smell diesel exhaust
in here today.
I don't know if anybody else
can smell it.
But it must be from the
construction equipment.
It's a fitting topic for the
air quality in the room.
I should have my little monitor
here.
So the idea that you would
create these aspirational
standards was embedded into the
Clean Air Act.
Fuel content regulations,
I think it's an interesting
issue that we've been more
concerned about what comes out
of the stacks and what comes out
of the tailpipes than we have
about controlling the fuel and
the process of its burning in
order to reduce those emissions.
So the idea of filtering what
is coming out at the end of the
process,
the combustion process,
as opposed to thinking more
carefully about the nature of
the fuel.
We made serious mistakes in
history, thinking about leaded
fuel as an example.
So lead was added to fuel to
make engines more efficient and
to knock less and to make them
less prone to breakdown.
But it spewed lead around the
world.
And recognizing that lead got
into the bones of children and
induced developmental and
neurological disorders,
that's a very important story.
So fuel content regulation,
in a way, there's an
interesting similarity to the
way that we feed animals.
So kind of neglecting residues
that are in animal feed or
neglecting the strontium-90 that
was in the feed that went into
cattle and then made its way to
our dinner plates.
It's similar to neglecting the
content of fuel and just not
caring about where it's going to
go.
So thinking about residues out
there in the ambient environment
as the target for regulation,
as opposed to the underlying
source,
either the technology of the
engine or the type of fuel that
is burned.
So indoor behavioral
regulation, we'll see that after
the break when we come back and
look at tobacco regulation.
So thinking about what is the
right of the government to
regulate what we do indoors in
our houses as opposed to
outdoors.
And the idea of building
certification standards and
development certification
standards.
More commonly today than ever
before,
we're seeing a variety of
different land use regulations
structured in a way that are
designed to reduce energy
consumption or to guide it in a
way that produces less air
pollutions.
So here's a suite of strategies
that might be used to control
air quality in a variety of
different situations.
So just a couple of quick
slides on key points relative to
the structure of the Clean Air
Act.
We have Air Quality Control
Regions.
So each state has to set up a
designated area as either in
attainment or at non-attainment.
And if you're in attainment,
you meet the National Ambient
Air Quality Standards,
NAAQS.
And states have to put together
state implementation plans.
The idea being that states
would have a better capacity to
know the behavior of sources of
emissions,
and it would have a better
ability to monitor what's going
on and to enforce violations of
the statute.
So the state implementation
plans have to have established
enforceable limits,
methods for acquiring air
quality data,
meaning that they've got to set
up a surveillance system.
Also, boundaries have to be
well identifiable.
They have to set up an
enforcement program,
and also have to demonstrate
how they are controlling release
of pollutants that could cross
state boundaries.
And also, they have to set up
reporting requirements back to
the Environmental Protection
Agency.
So what happens if a state
implementation plan fails?
I asked the question of the
head of the air quality division
at the Department of
Environmental Protection who was
responsible for Connecticut's
state implementation plan.
And he said,
"Well, we could have our
highway funds revoked or we
could have them seriously
diminished."
I said, "Well,
how often does that
happen?"
Well, first I said,
"Well how often are you
out of compliance with the
requirements,
the limits for the national
ambient standards or the
hazardous air pollutants?"
And he said,
"Oh, quite often.
In fact, southern Connecticut
and especially in the New Haven
region, is out of compliance for
ozone and particulate matter
routinely."
And I said, "Well,
does that mean that the state
has been forced to recommend to
EPA to restrict highway
funds?"
And he looked at me and he
said, "Well now,
we never really would do
that."
And I said, "Does that
mean that EPA has never
restricted or reduced highway
funds to the state?"
And the answer was no.
So you've got a monitoring
burden, you've got an
enforcement burden that really
is not working.
So you've got primary and
secondary standards,
and the primary standards have
to be set to protect human
health.
And the secondary standards are
set to protect environmental
quality and property.
And you'll recall the effect of
acid precipitation on building
stone as an example.
Criteria pollutants are listed.
So that this is a listing
statute, just like the Safe
Drinking Water Act.
The analogy there would be the
maximum contaminant levels.
But also the Endangered Species
Act.
And because it is a statute
where the chemical has to be
listed before it gets any
attention or is limited,
then it has the same political
dynamics as those other two
statutes.
Everybody fights about which
chemical is going to be placed
on the list.
So there are also a class of
chemicals, about 190,
that are called hazardous air
pollutants.
And I'll go through these just
quickly.
The criteria pollutants that
were initially believed to be
dangerous to health include
particulates,
SO_2,
NOx, carbon monoxide,
ozone, and lead.
And by the way,
all of these chemicals are
either emitted or they are
created from automobile exhaust,
just this one example.
But then we have this other
category that's called hazardous
air pollutants.
Asbestos, mercury,
arsenic, beryllium,
vinyl chloride,
benzene, benzene is a known
human carcinogen,
radionuclides,
coke oven emissions,
and coal tars.
So that there is this ambiguity
in language that's embedded into
the act.
Clearly, the criteria
pollutants are dangerous,
they're hazardous.
And the government has paid a
lot of attention to these six
compounds and not much attention
to the hazardous air pollutants
that include volatile organic
compounds,
some of which are ozone
precursors.
So how are these standards set?
What do they look like?
Well it gets a big technical,
and I'm not going to spend much
time on it.
But there's been an increasing
sensitivity about the danger of
particulate matter if it is
superfine.
So originally,
EPA went after particulate
matter ten, which is ten microns
in diameter, in size,
and had neglected anything that
was finer.
So that eventually,
standards were set for PM 2.5.
But take a look at the units
here.
The units here are kind of
fascinating.
So just take PM 2.5,
because we're going be talking
about that with respect to
diesel emissions.
Ninety percent of diesel
emissions are actually PM 1 or
less, so that they are really
quite fine.
So it's set at fifteen
micrograms per cubic meter,
and it's hard to wrap your head
around what that means.
Or sixty-five micrograms per
cubic meter, as a yearly
average.
And I'll come back to the
averaging issue.
And for some of the pollutants
there's an annual average,
for some pollutants there's
twenty-four average.
And this is extremely important.
So there's a politic that
surrounds the averaging period
that EPA has allowed.
And by the way,
when EPA wants to establish a
new limit, how do they do it?
Well, they publish a notice in
the federal register.
How many of you have ever
commented on a Clean Air Act
standards being proposed in the
federal register?
Really? You've done that?
Student:  Maybe if I had
any help from like Sierra Club
or something,
I'd do something like that.
Prof: Well that's great.
You're the first student in
about ten years that's raised
his hand.
But very few people pay
attention to the federal
register and very few people
have the capacity to comment in
a technical way that would be
potentially effective.
So here are the ozone
standards, the carbon monoxide
standards and lead standards,
and they all have different
averaging periods.
Well, it's worth your
reflection on how those
averaging periods are
established.
And I'm not going to go into
that except with respect to PM
2.5 today.
So the hazardous air pollutant
provisions were largely
neglected by the EPA.
And Congress got upset in 1990
because only seven chemicals
were regulated.
By the way, there are six
national ambient standards set,
you know, PM and CO and lead
that I just showed you.
There were seven standards set
for hazardous air pollutants as
of 1990.
And Congress said, "What?
This doesn't make any
sense."
So how many air pollutants are
there, anyway?
Well, just in wood smoke is one
example, or tobacco smoke,
there are between 2,000 and
4,000 different particles,
different compounds.
So particles of different size.
So the attention of government
on so few compounds is really
quite striking.
So Congress said,
"What are you doing?
What are you doing with the
hazardous air pollutants?"
And EPA said,
"Well, we've just been so
overwhelmed trying to figure how
to manage emissions from stacks.
And we've had a hard time in
just dealing with six of the
ambient standards,
so we haven't paid much
attention to it."
So they established separate
categories in the amendments of
1990.
This set of amendments was
probably the most important set
of amendments in the history of
the Clean Air Act.
And it categorized minor and
major sources and put into place
the maximum achievable control
technology standard.
Maximum achievable control
technology.
So it basically is
forward-looking,
thinking about the potential of
technology,
and in some instances,
setting standards that are
beyond what technology could
meet.
But offsets were also allowed
to reduce hazardous air
pollutants within plants.
And what that means is that if
you're a refinery,
say there's a huge refinery
with about a hundred different
stacks that exist between Los
Angeles and San Diego on the
eastern side of the I-5 and it
has so many stacks coming out of
it that those refineries and
other industries,
large chemical companies,
went to EPA and said,
"Well look,
we don't want to have to meet
these standards for every stack.
For the ones where I'm emitting
lower levels than what would be
allowable,
can I use that as an offset for
the emissions for the stack
that's emitting more than is
allowable?"
And this provision was enacted
to allow the companies to play a
greater role in trying to figure
out how they could reduce their
overall emissions.
Well, today for the next
twenty, twenty-five minutes,
what I want to do is I want to
focus on vehicle emissions.
Because it's extremely
important to our energy future
and our climate future,
but it's also extremely
important to our health.
It's affecting us quite
differentially based upon where
we live, how we behave,
and also our ethnicity.
And this is because different
ethnic groups have different
background susceptibility.
So all the principles that we
talked about with respect to
pesticides and strontium-90
about gee,
you know, not everybody's
exposed in the same way,
or not everybody is equally
vulnerable.
Or some people have background
illnesses.
Well, this is a story in part
about the genetic susceptibility
of certain populations that have
a higher prevalence of
respiratory illness than others.
For example,
whites have a lower prevalence
of asthma in the United States
than do African Americans.
And people of Puerto Rican
descent have the highest in the
nation.
So that's very difficult to
explain.
It's difficult to tease out
whether or not there's a
relationship between the smaller
ethnic groups and where they
live inside urban areas.
There's a separate debate about
whether or not there's a genetic
characteristic that makes them
more susceptible.
So I want you to think about
the vehicle problem for a
moment, which I think of as
enormously complicated and
enormously important.
So that the way that we've been
managing our consumption of fuel
and vehicles and the way that
we've used public subsidies to
allow us to move more freely
round our landscape has had just
an enormous effect on our
health,
our behavior,
as well as the quality of the
environment.
Two hundred and thirty-five
million vehicles in the U.S.,
about 320 million people in the
U.S.,
so that there's now one vehicle
in the country for everybody
that has a driver's license or
is eligible for a driver's
license.
So three trillion miles have
been traveled in the past year.
Two hundred billion gallons of
fuel, 600 billion dollars per
year at three dollars per
gallon.
And the average fuel efficiency
of vehicles in the U.S.
is about seventeen miles per
gallon.
Some of you are helping me with
a study of trucking and barging
in an effort to try to think
about reducing diesel emissions
from trucks,
tractor trailer trucks coming
up ninety-five.
Port Authority in New Jersey
receives about five million of
the containers that come in on
barges to the Port Authority,
and make their way up into
Connecticut across the New York
Border and move up toward Boston
and deliver goods in southern
Connecticut and Providence,
Rhode Island,
and also in the Boston area.
So that one of the issues that
we're looking at is could we do
something that would employ
barges to move those containers
so that it would avoid the
adverse effects associated with
trucking moving through the
region,
which is in part related to
their climate influence,
but also the really bad air
quality in Connecticut surrounds
the I-95 corridor and the I-91
interchange moving up toward
Hartford.
Those trucks,
by the way, get about five to
five and a half miles per
gallon.
How about the lag in adoption
of technology-forcing standards?
So say that you were the EPA
administrator and you decided
you wanted to do something about
this low-diameter particle and
you published a regulation and
went through the comment period,
by the way, that is governed by
the Administrative Procedures
Act.
And you mandated a reduction in
say NOx and PM.
In the case of particulate
matter and NOx,
this standard was proposed to
be adopted back in the late
1990s, 1998.
And eventually,
it was adopted following
litigation and following the
Whitman v.
American Trucker decision
went into force.
But it didn't phase in to make
any changes until 2006 and 2010
in requirements for engine
design.
So you need to think about kind
of the -- last night in section
I said it's like the glacial
pace of regulation.
So supposing the science is
really clear and it tells you
that the current level of air
quality or current emissions are
really dangerous and that
there's a link between disease
in the population and the
emission levels,
and you want to do something
about it.
Well, it's going to take you
probably between ten and fifteen
years to see any difference at
all in the regulations.
And what else is at play here?
What's the average life cycle
of a car?
Well now it's approaching
twenty years in the nation.
And what's the average life
cycle of one of these
long-distance trucks?
Well, that's getting close to
thirty years.
For some of them it's even
thirty-five years.
And by the way,
they don't throw those engines
away at the end of thirty-five
years.
They often move them into
agricultural purposes,
or the last resort of use for
the least efficient diesel
engine is now the fishing fleet.
So that old engines don't go
away.
This tells you that just
adopting a new regulation that
is technology forcing that is
going to demand a new engine
design that will emit less,
it's not likely to make a
difference for a long period of
time,
given this long life cycle of
the current vehicle stock.
Particulate standards.
So they revised the standard,
I said '98 a minute ago,
it's 1997.
And it focused health concerns
on mortality studies.
And basically,
they began to find that the
finer particles are more
dangerous.
And this, I mean,
thinking about it
physiologically,
anybody that has had
physiology, this should be quite
intuitive to you.
So why would finer particles be
more dangerous?
Okay, yes?
Student:  Absorbed
immediately in the bloodstream?
Prof: Well,
absorbed immediately into the
bloodstream.
They are absorbed into the
But why would finer particles
be more easily absorbed than
larger-diameter particles?
Student:  I know also
that small particles can act as
a nucleus and attract other--
Prof: Another good point.
These small carbon particles
act as a nucleus and they're
sticky and they attract volatile
organic compounds.
Yes.
Student:  The small
particles can get through your
body's natural defense
mechanisms in your nostrils and
stuff like that.
Prof: Okay.
The larger particles are
filtered out higher up in the
nasal pharyngeal cavity.
The smaller particles can be
embedded more deeply into your
lung and they can carry,
therefore, these other
compounds along with them.
So the finer particles are more
dangerous.
And we had started out with a
regulation of PM 10,
went to the regulation of PM
2.5.
And now most people are
thinking, "Wow,
diesel emissions are ninety
percent PM 1,
why aren't we regulating at PM
1 or even lower than that?"
In part, it's a detection
technology issue.
It's more expensive to detect
the finer particles.
More cumbersome for states to
try to set up a monitoring and
surveillance program.
So what are the latest PM
standards?
Fifteen micrograms per cubic
meter.
And I want you to focus on one
phrase here.
These are daily averages and
they're then averaged over three
years.
Averaged over three years?
Hm.
Well, when I first read that
and I hadn't really studied any
of the science,
I said to myself, "Well,
that must mean that the short
bursts of pollution really don't
make any difference."
I always thought that it was
not really a particularly good
thing to hang out behind a truck
or a bus on the highway that was
blowing diesel smoke,
and that there must be a better
way to drive.
So that in this case,
absolutely the opposite is
true.
The literature,
the scientific literature,
if you do a careful scan,
it's very clear that even short
bursts of pollution can have an
adverse effect on the
respiration rate and also on
people that have background
illnesses.
So if you look at the tunnel
studies,
for example,
in Europe, in Switzerland in
Germany,
particularly through the Alps,
where you have a lot of diesel
truck traffic that move through
those tunnels,
and they're often backed up in
the tunnels so that the air
quality in those tunnels is
exceptionally bad.
Well Lincoln Tunnel is another
good example of that.
So that they found that people
were having respiratory
symptoms,
using medication more often or
had to visit the doctor or be
admitted to emergency rooms more
often following these short
bursts of exposure.
So the short bursts actually
count.
Read Whitman v.
American Trucking,
it's a really interesting
decision.
The Clean Air Act,
the Supreme Court concluded
:unambiguously bars cost
consideration from the
standard-setting process."
Further, it requires EPA to set
standards "requisite to
protect the public health,"
"allowing an adequate
margin of safety."
So this is not a case like the
early pesticide law of balancing
risks versus benefits.
No consideration of the cost to
the trucking industry or to the
auto industry or to the
utilities can be at play as EPA
decides what the level is
supposed to be.
By the way, just the claim that
EPA had the responsibility to
balance benefits caused this
implementation of the PM
standard to be delayed for three
years while it was moving its
way through the courts.
What about the health benefit
of the new PM standards?
EPA estimated that when they
were fully implemented this
year, hooray.
Okay, they decided in 1997 that
they wanted this new standard to
protect health.
So that it's fully implemented
this year.
Eight thousand three hundred
fewer premature deaths were
estimated to be the result.
Seventeen thousand fewer cases
of childhood acute bronchitis.
And 360,000 fewer asthma
attacks.
Well, this is per year,
by the way.
So EPA was estimating that
every year of delay in the
implementation of this standard,
these are the health outcomes.
Now, how would you cost that
out economically?
Well how would you cost out say
asthma?
What factors would you consider
in thinking about what the value
to society might be if you
wanted to put this question into
a more utilitarian cost-benefit
framework?
Well, one of the things that
you would certainly consider
would be the medical costs,
costs of medical care.
So physician costs,
emergency room visits,
and also you have to be aware
that those that are poorest in
society have the least health
coverage,
and they tend to be the ones,
if they're asthmatic,
that don't get routine care.
Severity of response is a
function of whether or not you
get routine care.
And great studies about numbers
of doctor's visits related to
numbers of hospital admissions.
So the more routine care you
get, the less likely you are to
go into the hospital.
So it costs society less,
especially for people that are
on Medicaid or Medicare.
So other costs that might be
considered could be trying to
figure out how to bring your
child back up to speed in the
classroom because asthma is
responsible for more lost school
days than any other illness
among kids.
Also, when a child stays home,
when my daughter gets sick,
either my wife or I have to
stay home as well.
So lost work days also should
be accounted.
Had an interesting question
last night posed about,
well what about the economic
benefit side of the equation?
So should you also consider
some of the benefits of
prescribing drugs or benefits to
a hospital of having the profit
that's associated with use of
the drugs or the medical
services?
So I mean, setting up the
accounting system,
it's actually a very tricky
business.
Now, this problem of what's
coming out of vehicles has to be
thought about in the context of
what else is being spewed into
the air.
So small-diameter particles are
not just coming from vehicles,
they're coming from power
plants.
So that this map of where the
coal-fired power plants are
located, this is an old map.
But I'm using it just to make
the point that there are other
sources of particle emission,
other sources of combustion.
Forest fires in the Western
part of the United States,
in California,
also produce similar kinds of
particles.
And so that the background
level of PM in the Northeastern
United States is really serious.
Other sources include right
here in New Haven,
for example,
the tankers that come into the
oil tank farm here in the port.
And why is that significant?
Well, it's not as significant
here as it would be say in Long
Beach or San Diego,
where you have a much higher
intensity of shipment,
but these barges do tend to
burn high-sulfur fuel.
So that we're now burning
sulfur fuel, diesel fuel,
that's about fifteen parts per
million sulfur.
That's the new mandate under
these new regulations.
So the lower the sulfur
content, the lower the PM level.
Now, however,
there are certain parts of the
country that are allowed to burn
500 parts per million.
And the military in Iraq is
allowed to burn 3,000 parts per
million.
By the way, that's why if you
ever see like a convoy of the
National Guard going down the
highway and you're behind them
in a car,
it absolutely reeks.
It's because they're burning
this 3,000 part per million
fuel,
when your car or your diesel
vehicle,
your diesel car,
was burning only fifteen parts
per million.
And there are parts of the
country where it's allowable to
burn the higher-sulfur fuels.
Surprisingly,
including some parts of Alaska.
So think about where else these
particles are coming from.
We also burn diesel fuel in
Connecticut especially because
we don't have a good natural gas
source.
We burn it in our furnaces to
heat our houses.
It's virtually the same kind of
fuel, except it's allowed to
have a higher sulfur content.
And also railroads along the
ninety-five.
So the railroad corridor,
the highway corridor,
on top of coal-fired power
plant emissions,
on top of commercial emissions,
these are all sources.
Yes, question.
Student:  Is high-sulfur
content more efficient or
cheaper?
>
John Wargo:
It's cheaper.
So getting the sulfur out of
the fuel is a more expensive
process.
Question was,
"Is high-sulfur fuel more
or less expensive?"
And high-sulfur fuel is less
expensive.
So it's a matter of the degree
of refinement of the fuel.
So that in Connecticut,
I did a quick calculation and
found that we're burning about
230 million gallons per year of
diesel fuel in vehicles.
But we're burning almost three
times that amount in houses,
in people's houses.
And that has not been the
subject of regulation or
attention on the part of EPA.
That is interesting to me.
So that we're burning diesel
fuel right in the-- I'm burning
diesel fuel in my basement in my
house.
I'd better be sure that my
basement and my furnace are
pretty well ventilated,
and not everybody takes care to
monitor how efficient their
furnace is.
They may let that go,
especially in tough economic
times like this.
But your exposure could be
really quite significant if you
had a furnace that was out of
efficiency.
So particle size definitions,
coarse is greater than 2.5,
fine is less than 2.5 but
greater than 0.1,
and ultrafine,
just so that you know,
a little bit of air pollution
trivia.
The diesel exhaust that you see
here is only PM 10.
So PM 10 is just about the
limit of visibility,
which is kind of curious,
because most people think that
diesel emissions are much
cleaner than they used to be,
that somehow we've managed to
get rid of many of the smokers
as EPA calls them with more
efficient designs or with
particle traps.
But in fact,
we're producing,
yes, finer particles,
but we're producing more of
them.
So the idea that you have more,
finer particles that actually
have greater surface area to
lock onto these other kinds of
volatile compounds that I was
describing earlier.
That is one hypothesis about
why we saw the rise in asthma in
the nation during the 1980s and
the 1990s.
So what is in diesel exhaust?
What is at 2.5 basically is
elemental carbon,
a smaller amount of organic
carbon, some sulfates and
nitrates, and some metals.
Excuse me.
Going the wrong way.
Here is a diagram that shows
particle size moving from ten
part per million down to
one-hundredth of a part per
million, or micron,
excuse me.
And this is taken from Wilson
and Spangler on a book on indoor
air quality.
So that you see the
larger-diameter particles are
taken out pretty much by the
upper nasal pharyngeal cavity,
whereas the lower particles do
tend to get more deeply embedded
in the lung.
So let me talk just for a few
minutes about asthma and asthma
provenance in the country.
So about seven million kids now
have asthma, about twenty-two
million adults.
It's the number one reason for
school absenteeism.
And there are other critical
questions about what it means to
have asthma, what the effects
are on academic performance,
socialization and depression.
And I was teaching a seminar
here at the Yale-New Haven
Teacher's Institute about seven
years ago.
And I asked one of the people
in the class what the percentage
of kids in his class was that
had registered medications with
the school nurse.
He said he didn't know,
but he came back and he said
it's about twenty-four percent
of his kids in his class had
been physician-diagnosed as
having asthma.
I said, "Twenty-four
percent?
That's really extraordinary,
that's beyond epidemic."
So thinking about how this has
escaped public attention is
really quite interesting.
Mark Cullen,
who's now head of internal
medicine at Stanford,
and I worked on an asthma
report along with a group called
Environment and Human Health.
And when Mark was here in
internal medicine and headed up
the Environmental Medicine unit,
we did a survey in Connecticut
of asthma prevalence in schools.
And we found it did range
between three and about
twenty-two percent school
district to school district.
This is really quite striking.
We also found that the urban
schools had the highest
prevalence rates.
So we then thought about okay,
well what does this mean
relative to what we were
thinking about in air quality?
And this is an aside,
by the way.
And I just wanted to show you
the picture of a slice of a lung
tissue that demonstrates what
happens to the carbon when it's
inhaled.
It doesn't just go away,
it doesn't just dissolve.
It will sit in your lung.
And I've talked to many of the
surgeons at Yale-New Haven who
do sections and treat people
with lung cancer.
And I got into this because my
dad had lung cancer,
and I was thinking about
different forms of treatment
that he might consider.
And I asked the question,
"Do you notice a
difference between people that
live in New Haven and people
that do not,
assuming that the two groups
are both nonsmokers?"
And he said, "Oh yes.
You can tell.
You can tell by the grayness.
You can tell by the presence of
these carbon particles in the
lung tissues."
They take certain sections of
the lung out for those that have
operable lung cancer.
So then I started thinking
about what other kinds of
background illnesses would make
one susceptible to air
pollution?
And they would be people that
were asthmatic,
kids and adults,
those with chronic bronchitis,
those with emphysema,
those with coronary heart
disease and diabetes.
And if you look on the
right-hand side of this chart,
you'll see that the number of
people in the United States
diagnosed with these different
illnesses,
and you see the numbers are
really quite striking.
And you might pause and say,
"Well what do diabetes and
coronary heart disease--
" But this is very
important to pay attention to.
So fifteen million people
diagnosed with coronary heart
disease.
Well, they found that diesel
emissions have the capacity to
move through the bloodstream
once they're inhaled,
to cross the blood-brain
barrier, and to move very widely
through the body.
And they also tend to slow down
blood flow.
They tend to act as a minor
coagulant.
So that you can see an increase
in hospital admissions for
coronary events following
pollution episodes,
particularly during the summer
months in the Northeastern
United States.
So I'm going to run out of time
in a few minutes.
But I wanted to give you a
sense of how we understand air
pollution in the state.
And we basically do this by the
monitoring system set up by the
state implementation plan that
sets up these fixed monitors at
different sites.
So there's one right over on
State Street.
There's one Stiles Street,
which is just across the Q
Bridge.
And you see that they are
capable of picking up different
kinds of pollutants.
The Stiles Street Station picks
up PM 2.5 and PM 10,
another one in New Haven picks
up PM 2.5,
Madison Hammonasset State Park
picks up 0.03 down here on the
shoreline.
And you might say, why Madison?
And actually Madison has some
of the highest reading in the
state for Ozone.
And it happens to be because
the rush-hour traffic in New
York generally gets to this part
of Connecticut by about noon,
when the sun is highest in the
sky.
So you have the ozone
precursors coming in from New
York,
taking maybe four or five hours
after rush hour to get here,
and then you get the sunlight
coming down and acting on them
in a way that produces the
ozone.
So that the concept here is we
have about thirty different
stations set up with fixed
monitoring.
So what do the monitoring sites
tell us about pollution and how
variable it is across time?
So this is a day from midnight
to midnight going across the
bottom.
And what you see here is
different months of the year
represented by the different
colored lines.
And over here,
you see the PM levels.
And PM 2.5 has the standard of
fifteen microns as being the
federal limit.
That's when it's averaged over
a full day.
And these estimates are
averaged over a day.
And what you see here is that
some months are clearly dirtier
than other months are.
For example,
June tends to be,
in this year at least,
June was more polluted than say
December was.
So that there are certain
climatological patterns that are
behind this.
But you also see something else
in this chart which I think is
quite curious.
You see this effect.
You see a decline coming in the
early morning hours.
You see a rise coming around
the rush hour.
You see a decline that's more
in some months than others
coming back down for the lunch
hour and then picking back up.
This is an artifact of the way
that we drive vehicles and how
we're all at quite a similar
schedule.
And I'm going to leave you
today with this diagram saying
to you that you need to think
very carefully about these
averaging periods.
So I measure particles at
ten-second intervals.
And they're represented by
these blue squares.
And if you take the same data
and you average that data over a
minute, you get the pink
squares.
If you take a five-minute
moving average,
you get the yellow.
If you take a one-our average,
you get the purple.
And you get the red if you
average it over eight hours.
The PM 2.5 standard demands
that the data be averaged over
twenty-four hour periods and
then averaged over three years.
So basically,
the way that EPA would read
data would be over this
twenty-four hour average over
three years.
And you can tell from that that
it would compress everything so
that all of these values would
be invisible.
Even if you had blocks of time,
like three, four hours,
were pollution was
exceptionally high.
So when you put that story
together with the idea that
scientific literature is telling
us that we need to pay attention
to these short bursts of
pollution,
predominately because people
are experiencing medical effects
that are now causing them to
seek medical attention.
Okay.
That's it today.
We'll come back on Thursday.